the guy that called in last week he's in
a live-in
relationship with his girlfriend and
she's not banging him or or
or barely like intimacy is almost
non-existent there's always an excuse
so how would you guys deal with a
situation like that where you've lost
the frame
uh and she clearly doesn't want to be
intimate with you
so i gotta i'll just sort of i got a
thing that's like
i call it like kind of the four pillars
of uh
maintaining frame in a relationship and
it's
you got to start working on three of
these right away
and it's not even about trying to get
laid all right
you have to work on your mindset and how
you're seeing yourself
your sexual market value and your
purpose outside the relationship
usually if she doesn't want to bang you
it's because you became unattractive
so one of those three things is
suffering almost every time i have a guy
with this problem
those one of those three things is a
problem they let themselves go
they're stressed out all the time
they're not
you know they don't have a purpose out
there they're dedicated to her and
they're not dedicated to
whatever purpose that they're you know
they should see for themselves
they're in a dead-end job they've gotten
out of shape oh whatever or there's
something limiting up here
where they think they deserve this they
think that you know
they just have a bunch of limiting
beliefs things like books like your book
uh
all three of your guys books actually
and mine eventually if i can ever get it
out of editing
maybe right it's you know these things
are explaining the mindset that you need
to have and the approach that you need
to have so you can execute things
appropriately
something's missing in those three
things you start proving that stuff
all of a sudden usually by magic she
starts to see a little bit different
and maybe wants to bang you now fourth
part of that though
is seduction most a lot of guys aren't
very good at that they don't know how to
escalate physically what's cool about
pickup is you learn that stuff during
the dating process
so when you're in the relationship you
can execute those things
you know a lot of most guys sort of just
fall into sex
more or less by accident you know
because we are
human you know we are sexual beings that
are wired to just have sex with each
other so we sort of just
let it happen but there's a whole
seduction process though
and there's also the sexual experience
getting her
dependent emotionally and physically
from those neurochemicals
from having sex with you the intensity
of that sexual experience isn't high
enough or she's not capable
because of several notches and ability
to pair bomb whatever
but for some reason those neurochemicals
not firing to make her bought in and
want to want sex from you
so seduction would be that fourth thing
you work on now there's other steps like
if that's not working
fundamentally but working on those four
things solves most problems generally
you got to start with the first three
your mindset
sexual mark of value and your purpose
outside the relationship
and hammer that for like a good month or
so sometimes longer before you even
broach
breach the sex part of it because she
needs to see you differently she sees
you as a non-sexual being
she needs to see you as a sexual person
that she would actually want to mate
with
and that's that's what that happens so
it's like how do you start your oh my
car won't start that's why i hate that
question
my car won't start what's wrong with it
well that's a
[ __ ] expensive question like it could
be a hundred different things i mean in
general
in general it's usually because the guy
just stopped trying
and i hate to say it most girls actually
are pretty good but they're reactive so
like and i know this is gonna be a lot
of doing over the same terrain that paul
went on
but just being more attractive will
inspire more attraction
desire can't be negotiated doesn't mean
it can't be fixed
sometimes it's other things if a girl's
cheating on you with somebody that she's
looking to divorce you and get together
with him
for whatever reasons a lot of times the
girl will get
a dopamine rush from that relationship
to where
you're kind of like methadone she
doesn't like you anymore
you're in the way of her you're too
controlling in that case
the same things that'll make you more of
attractive when it's just a wife that
got mad you got a dad bod isn't gonna
work in that situation
other cases a lot of guys have like
super religious girls
that have had their brains just messed
up from the
work that their parents did on them
training them to think sex is bad and
they just assumed well now that she's
married all the and they're like yeah no
the hard wiring is still there
so like i said you got to break down all
this stuff but the key part
is what is the factor under your control
what did you do did you get fat did you
get lazy did you stop gaming her
get all that [ __ ] sorted out sure she
may be an [ __ ] and this is all her
fault
but until you know that for sure you
can't really say
now some then he said sometimes it's the
case uh post baby
hormones change what's that postpartum
depression
a lot of girls there are just like
mentally unstable maybe her psycho
psychologist got her on ssris then you
have that secondary discussion
which is like you said rich do i put up
with this or do i not put up with this
is she valuable to me enough that i'm
willing to work on this issue with her
to help her get past it
or is it just basically a giant time
sink
so then you got the work on yourself
section you got the how do you fix
section and the best way we've been able
to break it down and it's going to be
kind of the
road map for my second book is
get out of your wife's frame build your
own frame and then pull her into your
frame
three-pronged approach same habits for
everything
the only difference is the approach you
take like for working out just getting
guys to go and hit the gym to start
looking more attractive even if their
wife doesn't want him to leave
is a hurdle that's for guys who are in
their wife's frame
guys that are building their own frame
do i do trt what kind of schedule do i
want how do i plan all this stuff that's
great
pulling a girl into your frame how do i
bring her to the gym with me sexual same
thing
at first it's why won't she touch me
sort out that stuff you get out of her
frame you stop trying to please her by
doing more dishes
then it's your own frame how do i make
myself sexual do i need erectile
dysfunction
pills do i just need to stay in better
shape do i have issues with this that or
the other thing
simple problem a lot of guys have for
ones that wear them condoms
too small they think they're i'm just a
normal guy yeah no you kind of need
magums and the reason why you hate them
is because it cuts off your circulation
you're like strangling yourself all day
but you know what i mean it could be
just a small issue like that or it could
be an expansive thing
but yeah you really have to to get down
there's a soundboard from
[Laughter]
and then once you're into that then you
can find out yeah she'll maybe put there
and she'll just put in starfish
how do you get your girl to be more
exciting in bed and put out
but yeah it's like i said it's it's
impossible to give like a pithy
one-minute comment on here but let's
just see they're basically asking you
why doesn't your car start when you have
no idea because you haven't even opened
the home yet
before you go roll let me just um chime
in we got a
a super chat and i want to hit on um we
got
almost 700 guys watching and only 200
likes guys it doesn't cost you anything
to hit the like button so hit it it just
helps out with the algorithms
um if you're gonna click the join link
which i just posted in the chat come
with a
good internet connection have your
camera on and in the private chat when
you get in
let me know what your questions on um so
i can organize you
and bring you in if you have a grievance
or something that you want to like
talk about because you have a better
solution to a problem that we've
discussed
um bring it bring it you know let's
let's talk about it we got a superhero
from devon he says
uh davida suggests that some of this
behavior to be expected how do you
distinguish female
nature from intentional disrespect much
love
same thing yeah it's the same thing it's
no different
it doesn't matter if it's intentional or
unintentional still disrespect who cares
behavioral conditioning
i think and this is uh maybe this is a
david dita thing i don't know
he's a little kind of touchy feely we
were magic for me but i
read the clue even but um what's the
difference between intentional
disrespect and unintentional disrespect
right the only thing that separates
those two is the insight to know that
the disrespect has occurred and that's i
i was looking at james hicks they're
talking about well you know what's
maturity maturity is when your woman
knows that she's screwed up
that's maturity when the app when you
when she
knows organically oh [ __ ] uh
he's silent and that scares me that's
when she's mature enough because
young women have no sense of self until
they get to a point like usually the
epiphany phase when they realize that
they are the ones who are becoming
necessitists
so when a woman lives her you know
through her quote-unquote whole phase
right her
party years um usually during that time
she
is almost like selfless and i mean that
in the sense that she has no
like understanding of her self-conscious
being self-conscious
to the point where she would have the
insight to know that she
crossed a line because until that point
usually most women even the ugliest
women have some hubristic idea that they
like
the world revolves around them and that
comes from female solipsism
so getting back to the question here is
so uh a
sexless marriage first off i 100 agree
with with ryan there again it's it's one
of those death by a thousand paper cuts
i get guys all the time that say we used
to have sex in the back seat of the car
and she used to give me
blow jobs when we were out hiking in the
woods or you know that kind of stuff and
then now it's suddenly
uh familiar family husband
daddy sex now instead of of hot monkey
sex that she used to get which was
inspired by genuine desire
and that's really where i would go with
this is that it's inspiring that sense
of urgency and most guys
don't have the balls to experiment with
making that woman urgent
you know feel urgency right feeling
competition anxiety
because once you put the ring on the
finger once you sign your name on the
contract
hell once you decide to put your name on
the rental lease if you move her into
your house
then you will see by or by incrementally
order a degree women get more and more
comfortable and they don't feel like
they have to bang you don't have to make
that
effort anymore or they do it on their
own terms
so that's number one number two is this
is i would much rather have sex with my
wife
once a week if she was tearing my
clothes off and making it the most
memorable marathon session of sex that
we ever had
rather than having it five or six times
a week if she's just lying there going
you know are you done yet because i got
to finish the laundry
right that's that's i would much rather
have the genuine desire
than to actually have the frequency
because i would much rather have the
that that intensity because that to me
says this is organic this is genuine
this is not something that's contrived
or
uh as a part of obligation i had this
conversation one time with uh with pat
campbell we started talking about duty
sex
and women were losing their minds when
we
when you know christian women were
supposed to you know give it up to their
christian husbands because the bible
says that you're supposed to spread your
legs for 100
for your honey uh whether you feel like
it or or not
because that's you know your conjugal
rights or duties or something like that
women were losing their minds
and talking about enthusiastic consent
at that time
and i had to think about that and i go
you know it's it's kind of true because
one of the reasons why women will not
have sex with you is because they don't
feel a sense of urgency
they don't feel a sense of desire for
you an innate sense of desire for you
and they don't want to have anything
tell them that they should
because that goes against the uh the
existential fear of women right it's
oh my god i got with a beta who i
thought was alpha it was fun while it
lasted but now it turns out that he's
really a schmuck
when a guy lets himself go when he
when she lets herself go and they both
give up on the real not on the
relationship so much but on themselves
within that relationship that's when the
sex starts to decline that's when
the resentment kicks in that's and it's
not something
that you go oh let's go see the marriage
counselor the sex therapist and maybe
we'll go and negotiate to you okay honey
you're gonna have sex with me three
times if i do these things
and last but not least women don't want
to have that
handled for them they don't want to be
told that they should be into sex when
they are not into sex
the reason how i explain this is there's
a little thing called i forget the name
of it but there's a
there's the pink pill it's not the
viagra for guys it's like a pink pill
that's supposed to increase libido in
women
flopped horribly because women don't
want to have it they think they're being
roofied right
they're being like they don't have that
for the same reason they don't want to
be drugged and
taken home and raped right because it's
taking away that control that
hypergamous
control and that natural innate desire
for that guy so there has to be that
innate desire
and that urgency that dread that fear of
loss
because and if that's not something that
they can be insightful about and
something that they can organically come
to
then yes that's when you're going to
have those problems what do women do
when they say you know what i'm checked
out i'm going to divorce this guy what's
and and
you know six months before they even
filed the papers what do they start
doing
exactly exactly because they're
because you're not worth her natural
genuine desire for but some fictitious
guy maybe it's the alpha that she's been
widowed from or the alpha fantasy alpha
she's been reading about or watching on
a romance novel show or something like
that
that's the guy that she just knows is
out there and she's got to be ready for
that dude
she's not doing that for you because she
has
already her brain or id her ego whatever
it is
has already decided you're never going
to be fabio
you're never going to be the guy on the
cover of the romance novel
and she needs to damn well be in shape
because she knows what she has to do
it's not that she doesn't have the
urgency it's not that she doesn't have
you have mismatched libidos that's
[ __ ] man yeah that one you have
mismatched libido
that is like uh what marriage counseling
101 no you do not have mission actually
mishmash
libidos sounds like an article right out
of cosmos
that's why so and what happens when you
go say you know what okay baby i'm done
i'm going to the gym
for the first time in your marriage you
say i'm going to go i just got a gym
membership she'd be like
well what's he gotta what happened
what's going on you know that that
imagination kicks in
and now it's like oh sense of urgency
sense of sense of competition anxiety
people ask me like how do i how do you
keep it fresh with your your wife after
25 years it's like i work in an industry
where there's an awful lot of
opportunity for social proof
pre-selection and
not a little bit of competition anxiety
not that it's going to ever happen
but the possibility women don't want a
man to cheat but they love a man who
could cheat or is in a position where he
could cheat
funny thing too to expand on this one
hysteric bonding
a lot of guys don't believe this until
they find themselves in a situation
where
they're done with the marriage and they
check out or they have an opportunity to
cheat
sometimes they actually do the girl
essentially the girl is terrified
of losing the man in the relationship
divorce papers on the desk whatever
they find they get ridden harder and put
away wetter than any man in the past
has done and they think what the hell
happened i fixed my marriage because i
cheated
and it's not that it's because like
rollo said that anxiety that worry of
losing him
a younger hotter girl wants to sleep
with him and it's almost like a
manic need of mate retention i love this
because
hysteric bonding is the perfect example
of when you say
rolo the only agency a woman has is
their sexuality
and it's an unbearable thing and in this
this is the case she needs to hold on to
you
she has nothing else to offer and so
what does she do she will blow you three
ways from sunday she will
[ __ ] you five times a day and guys think
this is great i won the lottery this is
all i had to do
and a lot of guys mistake that for
genuine desire and then they think oh
good i can sit on my laurels
what happens then after three four weeks
she realizes she's kept you
the anxiety from the situation's worn
off things go right back to normal
and that's why a lot of marriages that
are on the rocks and are going
will have these weird off-again on-again
separation things
because the guy will accidentally have a
bit of status to himself when he checks
out of the marriage
the girl gets attracted to it because
they are reactive starts sleeping with
him like her life depended on it he
thinks he's won the lottery or done
something proper
and then to reward her he goes back to
his old self and then after two or three
of these cycles they end up leaving each
other saying
you know he was clearly abusive and
manipulating me i don't know what i was
thinking
yeah let me spin off that yeah i'm sorry
so yeah so this is why dread and how you
execute it is really
critical because a lot of guys really
eff it up right they really screw up
executing dread
they'll either start executing heavy
dread because of their
frustrations and their sexual
frustrations and they're mad
and after having a few fits because she
won't sleep with them
he'll start trying to give ultimatums
and that's their way of
like trying to execute dread well here's
the thing
she's already out of your frame and she
already
thinks you're not sexually marketable to
begin with
and you're probably already a lousy lady
to begin with and now you're gonna
threaten her with leaving
ooh you know what i mean like so that
doesn't usually work out too well for
a lot of times you know like it's just
like fine get the [ __ ] out of here like
what's wrong with you
so like they haven't built or goes the
other way where they do
that they don't actually think they can
do better and their self-esteem maybe
isn't
quite there yet there's usually if
they're sticking around and you've lost
frame there's two things either
one they don't actually think they can
do better and they're kind of
still on the hope that you're going to
be this alpha dude that you thought you
were
or two she doesn't want to be what i
call a bit a bad chimpanzee
where she just leaves the relationship
because she's a bad person she or she
cheats
um this is why most of the time women go
to marriage counselors and they push you
know
a want for that they go to the marriage
counselor because they want it to
appear they want to be able to say well
you know what i really worked on this
see i'm a good person i'm a good chimp
and he just
wasn't the guy you know so now we had to
break up
and so when you execute dread too early
without having your own sexual market
value and your own purpose
and what you bring to the table in mind
you can cause one of these two things
what ryan said
in which case then as soon as she gets
you back
fear of losing you goes away and it's
back in that cycle
or she outright goes oh really well
you're kind of disgusting to begin with
so
i'm out of here right so this is why you
really have to
focus on you and put out the smv and
your purpose and stuff and make that a
core
focus and then being attractive
right and not being unattractive and
then start working
on the seduction and then if the
seduction's not working then you start
working on that dread but you've now
worked on yourself a bit and you're now
better do you know what i mean then how
she saw you and you're trying to flip
that around i guess with your behavior
the guy that your wife or your
girlfriend wants to cheat with
that's yes yeah right exactly
you